MALE SPEAKER: So welcome
back at Devoxx.
I'm here today with
Chet and Romain.
And we're here to talk
about, well, Android.
Hi, guys.
You've been here many years,
and this time, this year,
you're here with a gift.
You came with a present,
and it's 4.2.
You actually made the release
for the conference.
CHET HAASE: Just for Devoxx.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes,
I know you did.
ROMAIN GUY: And not just us, but
a lot of people back home.
MALE SPEAKER: Absolutely.
You're just representing
all of them.
So 4.2 has a number of
end user features.
Do you want to mention a few and
do you want to maybe show
the device?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ROMAIN GUY: --show the device
to the camera here.
So one of the biggest new
features is multiple users,
only for tablets at the moment,
but you can create
multiple accounts, and each
account has its own settings,
its own applications, everything
is separate.
MALE SPEAKER: But you do
share applications.
ROMAIN GUY: Yes, you
can install the--
yes and no--
if you install the same
applications on two accounts,
we share the data.
But it's different
applications--
applications are linked
to your account,
to your Google account.
CHET HAASE: But it doesn't have
to get downloaded twice
for two different users.
MALE SPEAKER: So that's
a good thing.
ROMAIN GUY: We do have widgets
on the lock screen, so the
same widgets that you love on
the home screen, you can
install them on the lock
screen as well.
So you don't have to unlock the
device before you can do
something, like check your
calendar or listen to a song.
MALE SPEAKER: So you have access
to the camera as well
from the home screen?
ROMAIN GUY: On the
phones, yes.
You have access to the camera.
MALE SPEAKER: And do you want to
talk about the new features
in the Phone?
CHET HAASE: We can do that.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm sorry, the
new camera features on the
phone, or the camera
in general.
CHET HAASE: So there's a couple
of features that are
worth calling out.
One is HD--
HD?
ROMAIN GUY: HDR.
CHET HAASE: HDR.
I'm not a camera person.
HDR.
So you can take--
ROMAIN GUY: We invited
that guy?
CHET HAASE: Why don't
you explain it?
You're the camera person.
I'll talk about Photo Sphere.
ROMAIN GUY: So yes, we
have HDR on devices
that support it.
It's a high dynamic range.
It helps you to takes picture,
when you have a high contrast
in the scene--
for instance, you have a backlit
person or backlit
scene, you can use HDR to bring
back all the details
that are in the shadows
or in the highlights.
It works amazingly well.
We also have the Photo Sphere.
It's an extension of panoramas,
but now they are a
full 360 degrees, so
a real sphere.
And you generate photo, so just
a simple JPG that you can
share with anybody, but we have
special players on the
phone and on Google+ online.
And you have this interactive 3D
panorama, and you can play
with it and look around
and have this
3D feel of the scenes.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
I've used it.
It's awesome.
And I've seen people play
with it here, and--
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah, it's a lot of
fun to take those pictures.
MALE SPEAKER: It's
a lot of fun.
So quick settings--
there are few other features.
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah, we have
a lot of other features.
There's the new keyboard we have
just for typing so now
you just have to swipe
over the letters.
It's actually impressing,
like, it's amazing--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CHET HAASE: It's amazingly
accurate.
You spell out these sentences
by gesturing.
You think you're missing things
and it just interprets
the right word.
It's really incredible.
MALE SPEAKER: So these are all
end user features, so we all
benefit from that.
What about developer features?
So I hear those things
about being able to
drive a second display?
CHET HAASE: Right.
So we've got multiple displays,
and this is
interesting in a couple
of different ways.
First of all, you can have
a multiple display.
You can plug-in through say HDMI
to an external display
and the application can detect
all the displays that are
currently configured on the
device and can detect when
they're plugged in and
when they're removed.
And then it can choose to play
different content on that
other display.
And if it's protected content,
then you'll want to know that
it's a secure line and secure
stream to that other device,
and so you can query and say,
is this going to be a
protected stream?
And then there's also the
ability to, on the Nexus 4, to
play through wireless to HDMI.
So you can have a wireless
HDMI connection through a
dongle that's a separate device
that you then attach to
your display device, your TV,
and then you can actually play
HDMI, but it's just going
wireless the whole time.
And it looks like any other
external display device.
MALE SPEAKER: So from a
developer perspective, I have
two screens.
It's not just mirroring
the exact same screen.
ROMAIN GUY: No.
By default it will
do the mirroring.
But the application can request
to not do that.
And then it's like you create
a simple dialog on the other
screen and you can use your
normal views, you draw with
OpenGL if you want.
You can do anything you want
with that second display.
MALE SPEAKER: So use cases
would be, of course,
presenting, having a presenter
console, [INAUDIBLE].
ROMAIN GUY: A great example is
what we ship today, the Play
Movies application, we play
the movie on the second
display and on your home device,
on the host, on the
host, on the tablet or the
phone, you see the play
controls, so you can
pause, play, seek.
And you only see the movie
on the other display.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
Do you want to talk about
Daydream and what that is?
CHET HAASE: Daydream's our new
screensaver-ish thing.
You can create, these
applications that can play
when the screen times out.
And so you can see beautiful
things, like the photos in
Gallery that are wafting by on
the screen, but they can also
be interactive.
So if you actually want to--
some of those screensavers
that we ship are interactive.
Like there's a photo table, you
see the photos going by,
and you can tap on one of the
photos and it'll expand in,
expand out, you can fling
it out of the way.
There's another one
that's Currents--
it's a reader application.
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah, it shows you
the news from your feeds.
And if you see news that you're
interested in, you can
tap on it and you get more
details about it.
And of course, it's
a public API, so
anybody can write a Daydream.
It's very easy to do.
It's very similar to writing
an activity or a normal
application.
Again, you can do whatever
you want to.
You have views, you have OpenGL,
you have the canvas.
Very easy to do.
CHET HAASE: You always wondered
what was happening on
your Android device
when it went to
sleep and now you know.
MALE SPEAKER: Now I know.
Of course, so if it wasn't
obvious for people listening,
this is an update to Jelly
Bean, so this is 4.2.
Who is getting the
update and when?
Do you know?
ROMAIN GUY: So [INAUDIBLE] has
already started yesterday for
[INAUDIBLE]
Nexus and Nexus 7, and the Nexus
10 and the Nexus 4 are
coming out with 4.2
pre-installed.
And the source code is available
in the Android Open
Source project.
MALE SPEAKER: It's been
rolled out, or
maybe it's there already.
ROMAIN GUY: It's
already there.
CHET HAASE: The SDK came
out yesterday.
ROMAIN GUY: The SDK
is available.
The SDK, actually there's
a change in the SDK.
We now bundle, the
ID in the SDK.
So one download, you have
to plug-in the ID--
the SDK, all the tools,
everything is in one bundle.
MALE SPEAKER: And this is
all synced on level 17?
ROMAIN GUY: It's all
synced on level 17.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MALE SPEAKER: Anything else you
want to point out from a
developer prospective or 4.2?
ROMAIN GUY: Download of the
[INAUDIBLE] things--
we publish API difs, so you
can see the differences
between this new API level
and the previous one.
Go check it out--
a lot of little changes that
can be very useful to you.
They're not big features so
we're not calling them out
here, but they might save your
life when you're writing your
applications.
CHET HAASE: We also spent about
an hour talking about
this just a couple hours ago,
and that talk will hopefully
be available on [INAUDIBLE]
sometime soon.
So there's a lot more detail,
especially about
the developer features.
MALE SPEAKER: I also want to
take this chance to applaud
Google Developer Live.
We have developer advocates
running office hours and
presenting and they will be
spending some time on the new
version of Android, of 4.2
in the coming weeks.
So check out developers.googl
e.com/live/android.
So, thanks guys.
CHET HAASE: Thanks
ROMAIN GUY: Thanks